y
[Música]
a 5 días del golpe militar en myanmar el
ejército ordenó este sábado cortar el
acceso a internet en todo el país lo que
coincide con las manifestaciones masivas
contra el golpe y la exigencia de la
liberación de la líder electa y premio
nobel de paz a un samsung
la corte penal internacional anunció que
palestina es un estado parte del
tribunal un reconocimiento que abre el
camino para investigar crímenes de
guerra en los territorios ocupados por
israel en la guerra de los seis días de
1967 el primer ministro benjamin
netanyahu calificó la decisión de
antisemita
tiempo libia los médicos se enfrentan al
gobierno cuando el país se acerca al
pico de la segunda ola de kobe 19 el
personal sanitario sobrecogido por la
cantidad de enfermos rechaza la ley de
emergencia del presidente luís arce que
restringiría derechos gremiales
mi nombre es ángela gómez aquí comienzan
la mañana y también las noticias de
france 24 en mi armar la junta militar
ordenó este sábado el corte del acceso a
internet a escala nacional mientras el
país tiene su mayor manifestación desde
el golpe de estado del pasado del lunes
la teleoperadora telenor recibió la
orden de bloquear toda la red de datos
para impedir según los militares en la
divulgación de noticias falsas y
garantizar la estabilidad interna de la
nación 'aurora' va a ayudarnos a los
detalles
en mianmar no solo las calles están
bloqueadas la junta militar a ordenó el
cierre de internet de todo el país
mientras miles de personas marchaban en
rangún antigua capital y la ciudad más
poblada del país para denunciar el golpe
de estado de esta semana actualización
un corte de internet casi total está
ahora en curso en mianmar los datos de
la red muestran un colapso de la
conectividad al 16% de los niveles
ordinarios a partir de las 2 pm hora
local es probable que el apagón
informativo limite gravemente la
cobertura de las protestas antigolpistas
la junta a primero intentado silenciar
la disidencia bloqueando temporalmente
facebook el miércoles tras la
prohibición miles de usuarios se
mostraron activos en twitter e instagram
utilizando hashtags para expresar su
posición a la toma de posición hasta que
los militares ampliaron este sábado la
represión a estas redes sociales para
eludir la prohibición muchos birmanos
empezaron a utilizar redes privadas
virtuales que ocultaban sus ubicaciones
pero la interrupción más general de los
servicios de datos móviles limita ahora
gravemente al acceso a informaciones
independientes
no tenemos acceso a ninguna noticia
ninguna noticia sobre la madre ann
sanssouci me siento tan triste que me
duele el pecho
la ong human rigths watch pidió el
levantamiento de las restricciones de
internet mientras una portavoz de
twitter dijo que la prohibición socava
la conversación pública y los derechos
de la gente a hacer oír su voz
la corte penal internacional se declaró
competente sobre los territorios
palestinos ocupados por israel una
medida que abre la puerta para iniciar
una investigación por posibles crímenes
de guerra cometidos por israel palestina
que es considerado un estado por la
corte de celebró la decisión pero israel
que no reconoce al tribunal denunció una
persecución legal informe de federico
que barberena
es el primer paso para investigar
crímenes de guerra en palestina una sala
preliminar de la corte penal
internacional determinó que palestina es
un estado parte del tribunal y que
abarca los territorios ocupados por
israel incluyendo cisjordania jerusalén
del este y la franja de gaza
la aclaración es una respuesta a la
solicitud de la fiscal general fatou
bensouda que pidió al azar a especificar
los territorios donde pueden llevarse a
cabo investigaciones la autoridad
nacional palestina que solicitó una
investigación formal en 2018 celebró la
medida
la resolución es un mensaje para los
perpetradores de crímenes que sus
crímenes no estarán sujetos a un
estatuto de limitaciones y que no
quedarán impunes israel que no hace
parte de la corte ni reconoce su
jurisdicción denunció una supuesta
persecución legal cuando la cpi
investiga a israel por crímenes de
guerra falsos eso es puro antisemitismo
como primer ministro de israel les
aseguro que vamos a combatir esta
perversión de justicia con toda nuestra
fuerza y estados unidos a través del
departamento de estado apoyo a su aliado
israelí y expresó su preocupación sobre
la decisión de la cpi palestina espera
que se investiguen los excesos cometidos
por las fuerzas israelíes en la
represión de las llamadas marchas del
retorno de 2018 que dejaron al menos 270
palestinos muertos y más de 16.000
heridos
y también los bombardeos en la franja de
gaza- en 2014
sin una fuerza policial propia la cpi
depende de la voluntad de los estados
por lo que es poco probable que israel
entregue voluntariamente a posibles
sospechosos además el tribunal también
podría investigar a miembros de grupos
armados palestinos que son mencionados
en los informes de la fiscal
la compañía farmacéutica china sinovac
biotech anunció que su vacuna contra
kobe y 19 ya recibió la aprobación para
su uso entre la población por parte de
las autoridades chinas se trata de la
segunda vacuna que recibe luz verde para
su distribución entre la ciudadanía
china después del visto bueno que
recibió en diciembre la desarrollada por
un instituto de investigación de beijing
asociado a scinopharm un grupo formado
farmacéutico estatal
en américa latina' a bolivia a escala
hacia el pico de la segunda ola de la
pandemia y los médicos que siguen
denunciando condiciones inadecuadas de
trabajo están en pie de lucha contra el
gobierno por el proyecto de ley de
emergencia sanitaria el personal les
dice que ir a huelga si se promulga la
legislación que entre otras cosas
prohibiría el derecho a la protesta y
entraría a intervenir los costos de los
servicios privados de salud para los
galenos el presidente luís arse no
debería dictar medidas sin el consenso
ni la participación de los trabajadores
de la salud informe de emery back
la muerte
bolivia sufre con el repunte de
contagios y una de las peores tasas de
mortalidad del mundo por el coronavirus
eso no significa que el sector médico y
el gobierno de luis arse estén
trabajando mano a mano necesitamos
personal las reglas los médicos y las
enfermeras están triplicando sus turnos
aquí como usted cree que no se van a
enfermar no hay terapia intensiva no hay
es no es tiempo necesitamos ayuda y que
el pueblo sepa sepan todo lo que está
pasando los dirigentes de los médicos
acusan al gobierno de arte de tener un
doble discurso al aprobar una ley de
emergencia sanitaria que restringiría
sus derechos y firmamos hoy día un
acuerdo bien pero ahora ahora que pasó
estaban ellos sacando con la ley que
pues acababa con todos los derechos
gremiales con todo el derecho a la
protesta con todas las reivindicaciones
por los huérfanos las viudas el gobierno
ha defendido la ley de emergencia
sanitaria para afrontar la pandemia y
plantea
que la población se pronuncie sobre la
misma será que está mal contar con una
ley que regule los precios que
abusivamente han sido cobrados en una
prima en un primer rebrote de la
pandemia será que es mala una ley que
establezca que no se puede realizar
movilizaciones mientras dure la pandemia
mientras se declara una emergencia
sanitaria
bolivia tiene uno de los sistemas
sanitarios más frágiles de la región aún
más debilitado por el desacuerdo entre
el gobierno del movimiento al socialismo
y los sindicatos médicos
tradicionalmente de posiciones
conservadoras una disputa que ni
siquiera la pandemia ha logrado resolver
en otras noticias en francés 24 ecuador
elige este domingo es un nuevo
presidente entre 16 candidatos los
ciudadanos votarán al sucesor de lenin
moreno y renovarán la asamblea nacional
desde el jueves inició la votación
anticipada para personas privadas de la
libertad y en casa para personas mayores
y con discapacidad
nuevos disturbios en chile por un caso
de abuso policial un malabarista
falleció por disparos de un policía
durante un control rutinario y las
imágenes quedaron registradas en un
videoaficionado grabado con celular el
episodio pone de nuevo sobre la mesa los
protocolos de los carabineros grupos de
manifestantes levantaron barricadas en
puntos de panguipulli en la sureña
región de los ríos donde ocurrieron los
hechos
sigue cerca de la patagonia argentina el
combate de un feroz incendio que estalló
hace más de una semana en una zona
boscosa de la provincia de río negro
hiriendo a una persona y obligando la
evacuación de varias más la
conflagración destruyó más de 10.000
hectáreas a cerca de la localidad
turística de el bolsón en la frontera
con chile
y en estados unidos el presidente joe
biden impulsa el plan de alivio para
combatir la crisis de coronavirus o por
19 billones de dólares pero no ha
recibido el apoyo bipartidista esperado
en el punto de subsidios para la
población la propuesta incluye la
distribución de cheques de 1.400 dólares
a los contribuyentes una prestación
semanal por desempleo de 400 dólares y
350 mil millones de dólares para ayudar
a los gobiernos estatales y municipales
[Música]
hasta aquí el informativo ya volvemos
siguen france24
[Música]